i was talking to jimmy kimmel he's
telling me he's going to be hosting the
emmys this year and i went how are they
having the [ __ ] emmys
basically they're always having the
enemies it seems like they're always on
and i never know by what shows are
nominated like
it seems like it's like it's like game
of thrones dominated again like they get
nominated from like
that like six years ago like it's like i
i am so confused by the enemies in
general
there but yeah they they're they're
they're marching onwards thank god
but that tv series that you produce the
boys oh yeah
it is so [ __ ] great i guess that was
nominated for an emmy
uh for like a sound editing emmy i
believe
that show you did on showtime uh black
monday uh don cheadle yes
yes for the second time which is great
all of the shows
in the comedy category do you watch this
it's funny
chip's creek is funny and it's a
canadian show and it's like the fact
that a canadian tv show has broken
through in america is
truly unprecedented
it is it is absolutely remarkable and i
i could not be happier for
for those people and catherine o'hara's
on she's the funniest person on earth
and eugene levy as someone who grew up
in canada do you sit there and go with
pride can we finally produce something
worthy of an emmy i mean i actually do
uh yes i definitely do i think
and and i'm part of the problem because
i'm a canadian person who left canada to
produce american content you know
to make things in america so the fact
that dan and eugene levy
who you know could have made that show
anyway or made it out of canada and it's
a canadian show
is is wonderful and it's not something i
did so i'm happy that they did it
because also in general like growing up
you would watch a lot of canadian
television as a canadian and
the feeling and generally was like i
wish it was better canadians are funny
why are our tv shows not as funny yes
they seem like maybe they could be
it really is like a truly hilarious
wonderful show and the performances are
great and again i cannot emphasize
enough
everyone's funny on it but katherine
o'hara is like
truly doing so every i watch the show
and i'm just like what the [ __ ]
is happening right now like it is a wild
performance it is like a wildly funny
comedic performance
i will watch it based on your uh
assessment of it because i do love
catherine o'hara and eugene levy i mean
god
you